let me ask you the the doomsday question
all right and this is the doomsday
question this is not every day so the
idea to hedge gold against an
apocalyptic event where the economy
crashes
and uh you know the country becomes
insolvent now you still have some sort
of fungible asset to go and buy medicine
buy food why not just get a gun instead
okay but this is the thing i think
people need to understand as they read
the book is that it's already crashing
so you have a system it's called
capitalist system that means that it's
based on capital has the value we're
really not capitalization exactly
capital capital right now has no value
there's immense amounts of capital okay
look at the life insurance business like
it's not the same business it was 50
years ago because you can't get a return
on capital it it completely makes that
business turns it on its head right
because
you have negative real rates of return
and people don't understand that like i
tried to explain it in the book i'm like
look you're getting one percent go to
the grocery store it's ten percent more
expensive than last year no no
inflation's only six percent exactly
it's whatever they say it is right and
so and so what people what people are
are going to realize in a few years is
that it's the crash has already happened
a sideways crash is the same as a as a
down crash and you're in this sideways
crash now can you google price of gold
kilo type in price of gold kilo and go
to the second link that's goldprice.org
yeah go to gold
all right let's see go to the second one
right there 60 grand yep and then click
on
when it comes up go down and go to 20
years when you go to the site there's
180 grand on the table
so
so
the thing that's a good time to make a
run for it it's kind of dope
caroline left i wish i wish i had better
cardio go up and take the three days and
make that three days go down go down go
down right below the chart
to right in the middle of the black one
where it says three days go a little
lower says three days right there says
three days to the right
oh my god hi buddy come on tyler it says
three days right here
30 days three days right here it says
three days go to 20 years go to 20 years
you know pat ain't happy when he stands
up and points it's the first time i sit
down
right now that's been going away uh
personal trainer pat's looking good
these days he wanted to show up
all right so that's not that that's
about what's happened the opposite of
what's happened to your money now pat
let's let's real quick real quick sure
this is a 20 bill okay and this was
exchangeable for one ounce of gold like
if you look at this what year was this i
had to pay about four hundred dollars
for that for this yeah okay so so that
and and this one dollar bill was
exchangeable for an ounce of silver okay
and and so
this is for how much of gold one ounce
so that that give you would give you
this okay the bank would exchange it for
you that was the law what year
uh it says this was 1957.
pretty epic point he's about to make
about all right ready so this one ounce
of gold okay this ounce of gold has not
changed it came from nevada this is a
u.s eagle so it has to all come from the
us so this is a one one ounce piece of
gold one ounce is one ounce always it
has not changed now today i'm going to
show you what it takes to buy an ounce
of gold okay we're gonna have to make
some more room on the table because
the ounce of gold has not changed at all
since since the 20s and the amount of
cash that it takes to buy the ounce of
gold
continues to grow and the reason why i
think this relates to your chart there
is that people need to ask themselves
what's their the trajectory of that
chart these are all singles this is
singles but the reason it's a great
point he's making so he got on someone
he just did it's important to
to do it with singles because because
that's how you you priced right here i
mean that it's in dollars this is our
currency so singles are important i mean
if i just brought you know 20 100 bills
here i mean that's you know
it's we say dollars we don't price
things in hundreds of dollars you know
we say dollars and and this pile is
going to continue to grow yeah i mean
why would it not
why would it not we're in a debt-based
system
so why would it not continue to powerful
point you just made right there did you
see what just happened right there so
this one dollar
would buy you a silver coin okay this
one dollar bill in 1956 1934. they're
1934 this would buy you a silver coin so
how much is a silver 23. so 23 bucks
from 30 here's what's great is that with
silver that's a whole different ball
game because you've got to pay a
significant premium to get the coin
like you got to pay another six or seven
dollars to get the silver coin
that's what's so bizarre right they're
like silver's 22 but yeah the coins 30.
why would buffett put 35 million in
silver that's a long that was in the 90s
that's complicated you know that was
with fibro and there was yeah i mean he
tried he saw this and he tried to corner
and then and then he had to come off
yeah so so this right here 20 bucks in
1922 to buy a coin of gold right yeah an
ounce of gold same amount how much is an
ounce of gold it's 1800 so that's 90x
since 1922 yeah same coin
coin hasn't changed at all to give you
an idea what this 90 x means 1922
that's exactly 100 years in about a
couple weeks right so let's go 100 years
that means by 2122
that coin right there that's worth how
much right now eighteen hundred eighteen
hundred times ninety is what one point
uh seven million one point six million
now now here's here's what's sad okay
because i know this is you just you're
sentimental guy you can appreciate 162
your ancestor had saved up a thousand
dollars for you and put it in an
envelope and left you that thousand
dollars i mean
if we went and got a couple seafood
towers for lunch we would spend the
thousand dollars you know in one hour
okay but if that same thousand dollars
if they put 50 ounces of gold
think about think about the difference
generational wealth yeah so this is this
is one of those you know how your uh
parents you know when we were in school
they're like you know buy these coins
set it aside give it to your kids 30
years from now or something like that i
remember one time the uncirculated
nickels do you remember that whole
uncertainty yeah i got a case of
uncirculated nickels about 20 years ago
for 500 bucks yeah and i don't know if
you've seen these uncirculated nickels
you ever seen those things when they
would come out okay so it's literally in
a uh the tube that comes out it's never
been circulated to people you buy five
hundred dollars worth you set it aside
one day i'm going to give it to t-con
dylan and they'll sell it for whatever
20 30 40 000 right
you're saying this is one of those
things two three percent get some of
this set it aside
and like you asked me a question why
about here's why i bought gold
so you know for me i have around uh
seven million dollars worth of cards is
what i have okay
and the reason why i like cards is
because to me
there's only 25 of these in the world
this card right here okay this is aaron
rodgers rookie card o5
guy's got the best team in the league
this year some ways say that he could
win the super bowl whether he does or
not he leaves he does i'm probably gonna
end up selling this in the next five ten
years for two to five hundred thousand
dollars okay this card right here that i
paid 30 000 for
that's pretty proven unless if he does
something stupid like an oj story
something like that the return on this
is going to be pretty high
i didn't buy gold for that reason gold
is a buy for me of end of the world type
of a mindset it's not there's a slightly
of defensive strategy but it's also [ __ ]
hits the fan it's good to have a little
and when i mean [ __ ] it's the fan i mean
like
cyber warfare insanity crazy stuff not
even this uh you know bio warfare that
people are talking about with cr you
know with covet i'm talking cyber
because we have an experienced cyber
cyber's going to be a lot scarier than
it's going to be with kobe because cyber
you're going to be like
i can't even touch my money just notice
for a minute here we didn't have
internet how we felt you felt helpless
for like five minutes right like hey
what are we doing what do we do imagine
if you can't touch your
money you can't make a transaction think
about that's this all right let's go
there let's go that's coming over the
end of the decade by the way so that's
that's
that's coming that's the thing you're
pretty certain about it when you make a
make a a claim like that you seem pretty
confident about it that's the next
chapter because if you look i want you
i'm always watching people okay and i
don't like to have my phone and i watch
these people they're glued to the phone
right they cannot live without the phone
they have a panic attack if they don't
have the phone all their information
they get from the phone so we're
dependent with the phone and so if you
think about it if you want total control
of the society you already have people
bought into their money being digital on
the phone so you get that going now no
one can function without this and then
you throw a crash in there
and you say to people well unfortunately
the system was vulnerable it was hacked
everyone's in panic and what we're gonna
need to do is have an implantable
uh identification device that makes it
to where you know this can never happen
again and everybody will say i'm i'm in
put it in me
can you see this happening yeah for sure
before before we move on though the one
thing i did want to point out to people
you showed twenty dollars one ounce of
gold in 1920. tyler can you pull up real
quick what the average salary was in
1920
the average salary was 34 000 oh no no
no
32.69 32.69
3269. yeah okay that sounds and what's
what's the average salary today sixty
thirty four three thirty that's not the
right number that's guys it's twenty
twelve
thousand twelve so it was thirty thirty
3 200 20 x 20 20 20 x today yeah but the
money
90 x the gold 90s that gold is 98 what
i'm saying when it was tethered to money
absolutely so the actual rate of the
money that you earn
is one-third of what it was a hundred
years sure right so the hours of your
life for people that don't understand
what they're seeing right for maybe like
somebody that's younger that doesn't
understand like okay like whatever i'm
just trying to pay bills i don't care
about investing dude what this shows is
that you need to work three
times as many hours to get the same
amount of tangible wealth as somebody
did in 1920. so so so pat you're you're
a numbers guy i've i've put my entire
net worth and my entire life effort into
grabbing
decades
of
exposure to this
going up a little tiny bit in value so
like you go to 2500 on this which i
think is like completely doable it's not
a it's not a big ask to see this go to 2
500. people per ounce for a yeah
people waking up so you're waking up
right now like this is all boom it's all
hitting right now and as people wake up
to this 2500 is completely in the cards
and i've got decades of exposure to that
coming out of the ground with no
exposure to cost
yeah but you're playing a different game
you're not the average guy though so to
the average guy listening to you robin
hood account guy can buy one share of
the stock period it's
seven dollars i mean it's like you know
you're in i mean sure yes stock but
you're you're making the money in a
different way you've hedged yourself in
a you position yourself in a
a completely different game the one
percent that you're going to make
uh regardless you're in a very good
position so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]